okay we've been covering the state-level
proposals to make abortions almost or
completely illegal yesterday we talked
about Alabama no abortions other than
exceptions for the health of the mother
on the program tomorrow I'm going to
talk about Missouri and I've already
explained the sort of underlying idea
here which is that you've got a
right-wing Supreme Court now thanks to
Donald Trump more right-wing than any
court we've had in a long time so the
strategy is get some crazy bill passed
at the state level it will be
immediately appealed and challenged and
more than likely because it's so whacked
out and in many ways would conflict with
roe v wade it is likely to be struck
down by a lower court appeal it all the
way up to the Supreme Court and then
hopefully get a decision from this very
conservative Supreme Court that will
allow a national pushback on abortion
regulations everywhere there's a really
good piece in box that explains that
this is not just like a pipe dream for
the religious right that this is Rho V
wade in spirit and in name is in danger
because of this what I what I call
yesterday a very clever strategy by the
religious right but what I want to talk
about today is that even if roe v wade
stands legally speaking if it stays
enacted enforce the spirit of Roe be roe
v wade is in danger either way because
you can undo the effect of Roe vs. Wade
without actually undoing roe versus wade
in and of itself and that is a sort of
the premise of these really extreme
anti-abortion bills that have passed in
2019 four five six depending on how
you're counting and at some point
something is very likely to get to the
Supreme Court okay that won't by
definition get roe v wade overturned and
there are more and more analysts that
are pointing out astutely that
overturning roe v wade may not even
actually be the goal of these hands high
choice activists and it might not even
be the best thing for the anti-choice
movement the idea being if roe v wade
stays as the law that emboldened and
empowers the activism of the anti-choice
movement to say roe v-- wade is still
but we're working at the state level to
stop all abortion they can keep raising
money around the issue and you can do a
lot of damage to abortion rights without
actually overturning roe v wade itself
roe v wade in 73 at the federal level
said abortion is legal up to 22 to 24
weeks in most cases and so the problem
that a lot of states run up against when
they try to pass more restrictive laws
than that is that they conflict with
federal supremacy and roe v wade so
that's why lower courts will typically
strike them down and the supreme court
is rarely going to hear them because
it's pretty clear that they conflict
with roe v wade the idea here is you've
got a particularly conservative supreme
court if you can word one of these bills
in a way that maybe some element of it
or along some very narrow legal
interpretation the law would be okay at
the state level or a part of the law
would be okay at the state level you
could get a ruling from this very
conservative supreme court that will
without overturning roe v wade in and of
itself create a framework or a sort of
guide to how at the state level you can
pass something that would be more
restrictive than roe v wade the other
practical matter that would point to
this being a better strategy than just
trying to get roe v wade overturned is
that even the anti-abortion supreme
court justices may not want to attach
their names to overturning roe v wade so
whether roe v wade stays or goes in name
the idea here is that the principles of
roe versus wade can be dismantled by
these endless little cuts that could
come as soon as one of these state
abortion bans gets to the Supreme Court
and gets a favorable ruling even in some
sense and then they can make states be
allowed to have much more leeway in
deciding what to do about abortion and
maybe the most important thing to remind
you about is that with lots of similarly
to lots of other political issues that
are great for angering people and for
raise
money and for making noise but not
necessarily representative of the
national opinion most of the American
people are not on the anti-abortion side
and we have sort of two important data
points on this number one for the first
time ever a few years ago support for
abortion in what's called most cases so
obviously there are particular cases
where you do get a majority of the
country saying I'm against abortions in
that particular situation in most cases
more than half the country supports
abortion and that is a number that was
only first achieved a couple of years
ago so support for abortion has been
rising but even if you look at the
individual state level there is not a
single state where a total abortion ban
has even 25 percent support we're
putting on the screen a data analysis by
data for progress from cooperative
congressional election studies data so
understand that states are passing
almost total abortion bans even though
the people in not a single state support
that at even a rate of 25 percent the
problem is that abortion is a really
strong single issue topic so guns we've
talked about guns people are very a
partisan and extreme and by extreme I
don't mean extreme on the political
spectrum but very ingrained views about
guns but it doesn't seem like guns are
nearly as much of a voting issue as
other issues abortion is a really big
voting issue Donald Trump has lived a
life completely antithetical to
evangelical Christianity stated
principles stated being a key word but
in the end evangelicals voted for Trump
why cuz Trump now claims to be against
abortion and Hillary Clinton is
pro-choice and that actually is a big
voting motivator for people in lots of
parts of the country so roe v wade is in
serious danger even if the law in and of
itself remains in force I told you
exactly the way that it would happen two
years ago it is happening and if there's
any wake up call here it's we cannot let
Donald Trump get a third Supreme Court
pick we know how to prevent that from
happening at least potentially depending
on
what happens in the next year and a half
we've got to vote him out in November of
2020 make sure you're following the show
on instagram at david pakman show follow
me on instagram at david dot Pakman be a
photo blogging my upcoming trip which I
think many of you will find very
interesting we'll take a quick break and
be back after this